from healthier drinks to touchless
ordering at the bar the last year has
changed how people are enjoying vegas
nightlife we thank you for joining us at
6 30 i'm brian loftis and i'm david
charns kate houston stopped by
the nightclub and bar show over that the
over at the convention center
checking out all the big trends you'll
have next time you have a night out
from wellness teas to liquor infused ice
cream the latest trends are heavily
impacted
by the effects of the pandemic major
companies local businesses and some
celebrities
stop by the las vegas convention center
to get a taste of the next
big trend we're going to be in a
nightclub also in restaurants with
special flavors
jose iorio helped create booze cream
local business
selling 16 proof liquor infused ice
cream during the pandemic that we all
went through
one of the most sold products in the
planet was ice cream
and alcohol so why not
after a year of staying apart shareable
experiences like enjoying a pint of ice
cream with friends are growing in
popularity
we've seen i think things that probably
would have happened anyways
simply be expedited and happen a lot
sooner alexi kajavi with quest x which
helped put on the convention says these
are trends such as mixing healthier
options with alcohol like using tea
infused liquor
instead of soda technology was also
bringing in crowds with booths
showcasing high-tech appliances
qr codes and new payment apps through a
crisis
it really forces you to you know change
to adapt and to make
changes to your business and how you
operate and i think that will only
provide you know
a stronger sector moving forward kate
houston 8 news now
this convention is also tackling the
issue of staffing shortages they've
launched an employment zone to help
connect hospitality employers with
those looking for a job